Ucrania es la Unión Europea y la Unión
Europea es Ucrania es la frase con la
que el presidente del Consejo europeo
shakes Michelle selló El encuentro entre
kiev y Bruselas realizado este viernes
es el primero entre ambas partes desde
que inició la invasión rusa en febrero
de 2022 y el tema de la entrada de
Ucrania a la Unión Europea estuvo en el
centro de la agenda que hemos realmente
convenido hoy se entiende que es posible
iniciar negociaciones sobre la adhesión
de Ucrania a la Unión Europea este año
pero los representantes de Bruselas se
mostraron cautos estoy muy impresionada
y tengo que felicitarlos por la
precisión la calidad y la rapidez de sus
esfuerzos es fenomenal están en guerra y
aún defendiendo su país son capaces de
librar etapa por etapa el bloque exige a
kiev que garantice ciertos estándares
para ingresar al club entre estos
limitar la corrupción y una reforma del
sistema judicial de Cara a la guerra
Bruselas prometió entrenar a 30.000
soldados en manejo de arma brindado por
países occidentales y selensky pidió a
los líderes del bloque que las sanciones
europeas eviten que Rusia pueda
reconstruir su capacidad militar durante
la visita también se firmaron convenios
en aras de acercar a los productos
ucranianos al mercado común europeo y a
su futura exportación y Wander Legend
puso sobre la mesa un mecanismo para
reconstruir Ucrania utilizando los
fondos rusos congelados esto tras casi
un año de guerra que ha reducido a
escombros millones de hogares